hello there reject nation we are going
to watch squid game episode six gun boo
if you ever join our video hit that like
button or the dislike doesn't matter
democracy also subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified about
our reaction for the next game is up as
stated in all the other videos full
length watch along as we sync up with
the time code over at our petron page
cover a whole bunch of shows where you
get the option for reaction highlights
and watch along included over there as
well lastly thank you to pied piper for
editing these highlights for us you guys
are the bomb richard hendrix
[Music]
apology accepted it's all good man we
make mistakes glad they got punished
cop on the island speaking
yes a minor disturbance has taken place
but it is being addressed no need to
worry
[Music]
store 69
oh my god the right way
y'all
you want to team up with her
hey she's quite formidable man yeah i
would team up with her plus you might
want to have like two different types of
players they're wily like
you're the nicest guy
now go team up with the gang leader
no team up with the old man come on i
believe in the old man
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
yes
her there's gotta have something else in
mind
the teams have to rescue her
she's the flag go capture
um
[Music]
it
oh boy
brain tumor acting up maybe yeah
get to know each other
oh he's good at this game
oh my dude i want ollie to win i mean i
love holly
oh man
wow
it's pretty kind and dry for me i want
ollie to win
i'm a little conflicted i'm attack
conflicted but uh
mainly on all these sides
this
she just became best friends
oh okay i'm sorry i feel pretty bad now
oh my god all right i had it written out
over here it felt pretty awful about
what i said earlier
now that's what this show is designed to
do to you though
oh man
my
um
so
[Music]
sounds good
there's a different caveat to the
outcome of this game yeah
doesn't seem likely but i am suspicious
oh man
oh [ __ ]
that is so bad
oh
[Laughter]
oh wow what a choice to make
oh
it's [ __ ]
so crazy
oh
man
[Music]
money
[Music]
why would you trust this guy oh
you got this guy
shot
[Music]
oh
i [ __ ] had to feel it too it is
i had a feeling
[Music]
and that's why i wanted ollie to win
i've gotta get you
that guard's watching just like what a
sneaky guy yeah
i believe he thinks it's gonna work
yeah all right
haha
what if all this is an act
oh honestly i can't take that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
don't worry i'll
i'll lose the game for you
god
oh
[Music]
that's
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
damn
damn the old man's gonna win huh looks
like
[Music]
jesus christ
[Music]
[Music]
they didn't show them get shot they
didn't that's true they framed that very
creatively to where you only see the
edge of the room from above and the pink
guy from the side you know these
superhero stories
happens on camera yeah yep yep if you
didn't see that bullet go through in a
blood spray then he's still on the table
there was almost zero fun to be had in
that episode yeah
yeah we got the fun done like in the
first five to ten
and the rest of it was just like how
deep
can we take our souls down into the pit
of
just keep poking that despairing
depression bear you're trapped like hey
hey let's just make you even sadder no
matter what this isn't going to end well
no he's tricking the old guy the old guy
no the old guy's going to thank him the
old guy is going to tell him his name
is like jesus this is what i can see
see just doesn't end
they know how to shr they know how to
dial up the tension whilst also just
punching you repeatedly in the heart
just like everything with uh
and
ali and everything with the the the two
girls whose names i should know by now
actually we just learned both of them
this episode cutting me some slack we
learned her name in the last episode we
learned her name in the last episode
half slack not cut
but yeah i know like i loved i loved
what this episode did like i loved
you're already sitting in this tension
of like well yeah teams of two one
winner each this is going to be sort of
like a
not that it even feels like that but one
of those like pivotal like a red wedding
or something where like you know like
important characters we've been
following are probably going to end up
ill-fated and i love just the prism they
they shone that through the spectrum you
know of the two girls together which
becomes like a really endearing
beautiful almost zen bonnie experience
by the end of it and then you have
gihon and the and the old man in the
middle
trying to have like an honest game but
he knows like
you you've got this brain thing and
you're old and me and this and then
you've got yeah sang woo and ali in the
most like
in the position you absolutely would
never want to wind up in but like i feel
like that's the core sort of i don't
know tension of it all is like
yeah they they start with the best of
intentions but that's saying woo it's
shrewd yeah man
they just they're just stripping
everyone down to who they really are and
challenging every part of your uh being
no matter how good or base it's a
fascinating existential psychologically
driven
debate that they pose with all these
games especially with this one of
everyone's pairing up because they're
thinking about vigor they're thinking
about intelligence they're thinking
about strategy and little did they know
that they'd be going up against each
other yeah and so when you put them in
that position you see the true colors of
all this and the desperation is even
that much more enhanced and also the uh
internal conflict like i like how some
of these people were a lot of them were
just broken down just stripped down into
tears you know as i'm sure like like i
was at times and i'm sure some of you
guys were like that that emotion of
like with the two girls you know that
just [ __ ] broke me
like yeah damn it man like this is the
first time we were like we only got to
know one of them in the last episode
sort of and this is where we're really
getting to know them
and just the choice of sacrifice it was
just so heartbreaking
and then on on the flip side there with
ali and uh what's his name seng wu sang
woo
that dick you know like
he has he's a great actor though you got
to give him credit because he has the
ability to make you
to why you know everyone who trusts him
and confides in him but they have these
little touches that the dirt that they
capture with their direction that show
you that he is just conniving and he's
only out for himself as everyone else is
you're like everyone's out for
themselves pretty much that's that's
what was so
crazy about the sacrifice was the
selfless act yeah you know like i just
got to know you right now and i'm going
to sacrifice myself in this game that is
about survival of the fittest and last
man standing essentially
to to have a selfless act like that was
just so heartbreaking
um but like ali you know he's this is an
honest guy and he's a nice guy he's a
caring dude and he even saved our main
dude in the first episode you know yeah
like he was so he's just so sincere and
so nice and so to have uh to have him
just get betrayed like that and for that
to be his final moments and to just know
he has like a wife and a and a and like
a one-year-old out there just [ __ ]
this shatters me man and i already loved
him he was sort of my favorite character
but they you know they really do paint
him like they even just write down him
choosing ollie you know like doesn't
consult anyone it just immediately goes
no all the yeah you'd be the best you're
my buddy partner up with on and to win
this game and take it to the end and be
like hey you and i together teams all
the way i'm gonna motivate you but you
know like he wound up in the financial
debt situation he's in due to sleazy
decisions and bad gambling choices
essentially it wasn't like gambling
necessarily but there's kind of like
playing like stocks and stuff business
gambling you know
yeah not that petty vegas yeah yeah but
listen to futures man but then yeah with
uh the old man and um
how do you say i'm always self-conscious
that i'm saying his name wrong the main
guy i think i i to the best of what i
can grab in the yeah and the subtitles
and i think it's just gihon just the
easiest way at ki hoon yeah all right
but what's the one the letter with the s
the name of the s oh that's that's
that's where my name gets that's where
he's that's where he's from yes yes
because he's established several times
that's not what my name is yeah
oh gihon
um
it is and like i've talked about it
before that's like parallel to the draw
that he could evolve into this old man
essentially you know like it wasn't it
was just a few episodes ago where he was
struggling to get a proper gift for his
daughter stellar's birthday was just
recently too and here he is and like
even as they're walking down the
alleyway
going the old man's like i grew up in a
place like this and hinging on like you
said yeah so did i like like this this
parallel that they draw
between where gi hoon could end up
you know it's
it it's so uh it is tragic
just because of like
the old man i don't know like did he
know the whole time is any of this an
act of what he's doing you know like it
doesn't seem that way
um
at but at the same time you know it's
like you can't blame
this
i guess you can't if you can't blame you
because he's working with something
that's not like he thought he thinks
he's working with a guy with dementia
yeah like a dude who's ill and he and
and it's like well
there's no way this guy could possibly
transgress
yeah there's no way this guy can win
and i'm dealing with this situation here
where honestly it's not going to work
for me i'm trying to tell him we have to
plan it's not working yeah uh and he
can't play a fair game because he's just
playing playing it that way doesn't seem
to be panning out for him but then when
they were playing the game he was losing
and he did cheat
uh to trick him uh a couple of times
that
then they did that really beautifully
too honestly this episode left me with
shame and feeling hollow uh it is not a
good feeling it is like how a lot of
koreans was like
take that shower and cry it out
because i was just i just felt very i
felt very empty by the end in a way that
wasn't like i like detached in the way
of just like this is so devastating
non-stop
um and then the [ __ ] dude
winds up winning
oh yeah bastard you knew it somehow you
knew it i had a feeling he was going to
get his ball knocked down like his ball
going and knocked it out feelings don't
want to say it and i was like is that
within the rules does it does it count
but i guess yeah it doesn't make sense
yeah
yeah well they're also making up their
own rules yeah absolutely but like
that's that's i think the great thing
about this episode is yeah it makes you
feel all those things and it does a nice
job of exploring the spectrum because it
already is making you go damn what would
i do the whole show is what would i do
in this situation but especially in this
one i feel like they show you an array
of different pairs and in doing so they
show you different reflections of who
you might be and i feel like that one
moment especially where he questions oh
would you say even or odd like that is
it's a choice it's the most uh relatable
show because i think dilemma
like most people in that scenario would
be like
yeah the correct answer yeah and you
know it's like sitting there thing is
like you know who would be the one to
say like no i said odd when it was even
i mean when it's life or death on the
line you know it just changes the game
yeah and it makes you wonder further
because i was sitting there in that
scene going is the old man giving him an
in for the is he literally like handing
it to him and being like what did you
say here's a chance to correct your
answer because maybe he knows that
ultimately you should probably progress
given what you have to live for and
given my advanced age and condition and
whatnot but like there's never anything
definitive so when they have that
ultimate little end moment even then i
was like is he
is he guilty him like he seems like he's
pretty well aware that he has been
deceived somewhat in the steps of this
game you know and yet they still end off
on such a a beautiful little note it's
like a bittersweet
opposite to you know the the two women
who like
have this very sort of selfless and
emotional moment and you know it's like
the same kind of outcome happens he
gives it to him but it's like the
completely hollow version of that well
it one ends with deception yeah yeah
absolutely i
yeah i think what's great about the
games of how they've been progressing is
the games have slowly been
not so
physical and about how robust you are or
whatever it's been about
your psyche mainly
like they've been not only breaking them
down wear and tear on their bodies but
then as they've been progressing
it's been about breaking who they are
down mentally and emotionally
and that's in some ways a harder
challenge yeah because then that's about
who you are as a person you know choices
this is [ __ ] up man should have gone
with that crazy [ __ ] woman who was
you know choose me pick me oh yeah
that's gonna become of her she's gonna
be back she'll be back she probably had
to do a solo game i mean they didn't
kill her it did not explicitly not
obviously so she's got to be
i don't know they keep preaching about
fairness so i'm like
there's got to be some provision for her
i don't know man we'll see
all right well [ __ ] that was hard
that was a tough one to sit there yeah
that hurt that was tough it feels
horrible [ __ ] right there i know
so many feelings right now i can't
believe they just did that damn i heard
episode six was gonna be a hum dinger
and i still wasn't prepared
oh [ __ ] we're on six
yeah that was six
okay
we were watching five last count man
okay yeah that was that was hard that
was hard all right well
hey
what do you know
let's uh let's get this show on the road
thanks for being here hit the like
button let's do a pic
eric horstmann if we're playing this
marbles game
you know what i would totally sacrifice
myself to make sure
you can keep on going and by making that
choice
i know you would not accept me
sacrificing myself
so then you would ultimately just throw
your marbles my way make sure i have all
20 marbles and then you would walk away
dead sacrificing yourself for me that's
why for this game i would choose you by
me showing my selfless humble act
of giving up my life
i would ultimately be able to manipulate
you
into giving up and you know it's true
if anyone's met eric you know it's true
if he loves you he'll do it if he
doesn't love you he'll just kick you in
the balls and take those marbles too
that's the way that man works so eric
i'm glad we're on the same team for this
one around man
[Music]